wake up java the bow don't sweat now
peace well
it's a beautiful day gonna burn my truck
I'm going
the top
I'm go all that
the bus now
you may have already deck the hall and
popped out all your presents under the
tree as soon as it's her November but
why stop there let's go straight into
spring and talk about easter eggs befall
our games are full of little references
to other things that the developers
loved Star Wars Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy old video games Firefly The
Simpsons South Park Batman die hard The
Legend of Zelda basically if it's nerdy
pop culture it's in the game we've baked
our 10 favorite Easter eggs from across
the Fallout series with only five months
to spare yes when you enter gold ribbon
grosses in fallout 3 you probably expect
to find some ghouls some skeletons or a
very least a deathclaw who wants to turn
your insides into outsides instead you
find the pet project of one very bored
wastelander or game designer it's known
as a Rube Goldberg machine which is an
overly complicated set of reactions
designed to do something simple like
crack an egg you may have seen them in
car adverts music videos in the whole of
final destination but this one is pretty
simple involving cereal box dominoes
lots of explosions and a skeleton at the
end surprised if you have the wild
wasteland perk you can expect to see
some pretty weird things as you wander
around the game one of these things is
strike a little deathclaw that you can
find inside a doghouse in Hicks village
named after the main antagonist from
gremlins even though he's clearly
someone's pet he's not been tamed at all
and will attack on site remember guys
and deathcrows for life not just for
Christmas
people working on fallout must have a
huge Monty Python fans because the
wasteland is stuffed references the
Flying Circus the Monty Python films and
all the British you nonsense within our
favorite one is a reference to Monty
Python of the Holy Grail the holy hand
grenade of antioch it does look like a
regular grenade but probably full of
holiness and plenty of crap the classic
dogs playing poker paintings were
originally commissioned by advertising
company Brown and Bigelow in 1903 to
sell cigars exactly how dogs playing
cards relates to smoking is unclear but
nevertheless the image has become an
instantly recognizable one in fallout
you can find Robo dogs playing poker
because it's the future around the area
where the Robo dogs are trained Robo
dogs work hard and play hard futurama's
jurassic park episode ranks up there
with dogs playing poker on our top 10
iconic dogs of entertainment in the
episode fries dogs seem always years for
the return of his owner only to die
alone and sad at the age of 15 he then
becomes fossilized and placed in a
museum where is found by fri button
fries given the chance to bring his
beloved pooch back to life he decides to
leave and fossilized thinking that
Seymour's age meant that the poor pup
had lived a full life and here he is in
fallout still alone still sad and still
making grown men cry in London where we
all wear bowler hats and drink tea and
drive Rolls Royces to work a doctor who
reference is so incredibly last year
darling we're so surrounded by telephone
boxes and strange men and bowties that
doctor who is actually just a
documentary of what it's like to live
here nevertheless we did quite enjoy
this reference to the doctor's method of
travel a TARDIS that pops in and out of
the wasteland in the original fallout
sniffing work chaps original studios
that works on Fallout interplay and
Black Isle both vanished into the
wasteland after Podesta talk over
interplays logo can be seen on fallout 3
and the words Black Isle in different
languages can be found scattered around
the place like isla negra a company
mention of Fallout 3's Point Lookout DLC
and a reference to a destroyed ship
named eban at all
if you want to dress up as a cool dude
for a fancy dress party you have a
roughly fifty percent chance of dressing
as a Harrison Ford character hats and
webs for Indiana Jones waistcoats and
sass for Han Solo guns and grumpiness
with bladerunners Rick Deckard Deckard's
iconic gun was recreated and fallout and
named that gun because apparently that's
what everyone was calling it anyway and
the canceled fallout film was meant to
have several scenes from Blade Runner
there we'll never know whether this
means on a TV in the background or just
sliced right into the footage but it's
not the only harrison ford movie that
fallout has taken inspiration from we
really wish that the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull had never happened but
whilst they gave a Shia LaBeouf in
leathers and a really stupid plot
involving aliens it also gave us his
easter egg and fall out where you can
find dr. Jones's corpse in a fridge a
reference to him hiding inside a fridge
to survive a nuclear bomb FYI ndn that
wouldn't save you in fact you're likely
to die from suffocation overheating
irradiation a snap neck impact upon the
floor or if you survive all of that
being drowned in molten lead some
professor you are also you can see this
hat somewhat unsurprisingly fallout
takes a lot of inspiration from fellow
wasteland survival dude Mad Max the man
and dog friendship the leather armor the
pit arena that looks an awful lot like
the Thunderdome an actual Mel Gibson are
all things to be found and fall out
there are so many Mad Max references
that fallout sort of comes across as a
bit of a creepy secret admirer that has
a shrine to Mel Gibson in their wardrobe
chill out fallout jeez so those are our
10 favorite Easter eggs if you'd like to
let us know what your favorite Easter
eggs are or if we've completely
misunderstood wine easter egg is let us
know in the comments now comes the part
of the show where we take a moment to
look at some of the awesome creations
from the community I'm going to start
off with Pierre and another Lego fallout
4 LEGO creation I know he did one last
week but these are amazing I couldn't
even build a house that matched the same
color when I was a kid and here's
someone making soups of power armor hit
boys dog meets and entire fall out
garages have tiny little bricks it seems
like it's a bigger scale my last one
but I mean the only gripe I have is the
vault boy is quite creepy now kingdoms
are long destroyed and fall out but that
doesn't stop her from being princesses
so Penta saw has actually drawn Disney
recreations of princesses inside fall
out and they all match their characters
so Snow White being friend to the animal
the mole rat Ariel sitting on a crab I
mean I hope that's not Sebastian he's is
that hard enough time that alice is
obviously a jet junkie because well they
might have said just inhale this on the
inhaler icon judge and Rapunzel just has
a frying pan and gonna kill a rad roach
that probably last longer in the
wasteland than i would so no judgment
and finally i was lucky enough to attend
gamer bake a fallout based cake sale all
in aid of games a charity and it was it
was a wonderful time of cakes not only
looks great but they were delicious i I
made shots bring back some to the office
all the cakes befall our themes so we
had a giant bowl 77 cake there we had
tiny little vault or cookies nuka-cola
quantum cupcakes and my favorite being
the the mole rat cake which looked both
better and more terrifying before it was
hacked to pieces with with a cake life
so those are some of the greatest
creations to come out from the fallout
community in the past week if you've
made anything awesome that you want to
share make sure you use the hashtag GS
fall out and post its Twitter until next
time thank you so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe to the
fallout 4 show and we'll see you next
time wastelander